at this altitude i can run flat out for
a half mile before my hands start to
shake
can i answer your personal question
[Music]
i'm a cybernetic organism living tissue
over metal
[Music]
this episode is brought to you by
butcherbox butcherbox makes it easy for
you to get high quality humanely raised
meat that you can trust
they deliver delicious 100 grass-fed
grass-finished beef
free-range organic chicken heritage
breed pork and wild caught seafood
directly to your door for me in the past
few weeks
i've cooked a ton of their salmon as
well as two delicious barbecue rib racks
in the oven super simple they were the
most delicious pork ribs i've ever
prepared
and my freezer is full of butcher box
when you become a member
you're joining a community focused on
doing what's better for all that means
caring about the lives of animals
the livelihoods of farmers treating our
planet with respect and enjoying
better meals together butcherbox
partners with folks small farmers
included who believe in going above and
beyond when it comes to caring for
animals the environment and
sustainability
and none of their meat is ever given
antibiotics or added hormones
so how does it work it's pretty simple
you choose your box and your
delivery frequency they offer five boxes
four curated box options as well as the
popular custom box so you get exactly
what you
and or your family love box options and
delivery frequencies can be customized
to fit your needs you can cancel at any
time
with no penalty butcherbox ships your
order frozen for freshness and packed in
an eco-friendly 100
recyclable box it's easy it's fast
it's convenient i really really enjoy it
and best of all looking at the average
cost it works out to be less than six
dollars per meal and for a limited time
new members can get two pounds of free
ground beef in every butcher box order
by signing up today at butcherbox.com
tim that's up to 180 in savings per year
check it out all the details and goodies
can be found at butcherbox.com
tim again that's butcherbox.com
tim
this episode is brought to you by thrive
market thrive market saves me a ton of
money and it's perfect for these crazy
times
thrive market is a membership-based site
on a mission to make healthy living
easy and affordable for everyone you can
regularly save 25 to 50 percent off of
normal retail prices with member-only
prices for
anything you can imagine really whether
it's keto paleo gluten free vegan
whatever you can sort by that
you can find all types of food you can
find supplements you can find non-toxic
home products
clean wine dog food just about anything
and let me give you a personal example
of just how much
you can save so my last order i ordered
primal kitchen
mayonnaise which is made with avocado
oil it's delicious justin's almond
butter
and the first was 25 off the
justin's almond butter was 30 off rous
homemade marinara sauce which is awesome
26
off all said and done at the end of my
shopping i saved 39 on
my order so members and i'm a member can
earn wholesale prices every day and save
an
average of 30 on each order i'll come
back to that
and through thrive gives their
one-on-one membership matching program
every paid
thrive market membership is matched with
a free one for a low income family in
need so go to thrivemarket.com
tim today to give thrive market a try
you can select the membership model that
best fits your lifestyle they have one
month
and 12 month membership options choose a
free gift up to 22
in value when you join today and
purchase the one year membership and
just remember
thrive market membership is risk free
you can take the first 30 days to decide
if thrive market is right for you if
it's not just cancel within those 30
days and get a full refund
this is what i offered my mom so again
that's thrivemarket.com
tim by the way my mom kept using it
thrive market dot com
slash tim check it out
hello boys and girls ladies and germs
this is tim ferriss and welcome to
another episode of
the tim ferriss show where it is my job
to deconstruct world-class performers
from all different walks of life
my guest today is none other than writer
chuck
pollinik chuck has published 23 national
and international best-selling books
give me a second to pick my broken
self-esteem off the floor
these include 15 prose novels a
collection of short stories two graphic
novels two coloring books a travel guide
a collection of essays and a memoir
about his life as a writer which i
highly highly recommend
he was raised in a desert town with a
population of 300 at the time of his
birth in 1962. he received a bachelor's
degree in journalism from the university
of oregon
paula nick is best known for his novels
fight club and shook both of which were
made into films
publication of his short story guts in
sunday guardian prompted a sharp drop in
circulation he frequently contributed
fiction to playboy
where his stories romance cannibal and
zombie had to be personally approved
by hugh hefner his new book the
invention of sound
comes out on september 8th you can find
him on the web
chuck paulinick.net on twitter
facebook and instagram also all under
the handle
of chuck palahniuk chuck welcome to the
show
hey thank you very much tim and i want
to start with a few questions about the
bio
specifically guts in the sunday guardian
why did that prompt a sharp drop in
circulation
you know i'd always been fascinated by
the fact that when shirley jackson
published the lottery in the new yorker
the new yorker lost something like 500
subscribers people who were so
offended by that story and i always
thought
what would it take these days for a
story
to offend people that much that they
would actually cancel
subscriptions and uh i ended up becoming
acquaintances with shirley jackson's
daughter who sent me a big chunk of
shirley's
cremains her their burned up remains
and so having shirley's ashes in my
house
i just had to write a story that would
be as offensive as the lottery was
and uh playboy published it originally
had turned it down
but then the editor chris napolitano
came to an event and saw people faint
while i was reading guts so he had to
buy it
and then in england the guardian had to
buy it they ran it in their sunday
literary supplement and they later
reported to me that
a huge number of their subscribers had
canceled after that was published
what was it about guts what was it in
the the narrative or the content
that caused people to faint and cause
them to unsubscribe
the a doctor in cambridge witnessed a
bunch of people faint
and he explained to me that watching the
way that their heads fell to one side
was a classic form of hyperventilation
that they laughed so much through the
first part of the story
that their their blood became what's it
is alkali typically and then it becomes
acid once it's
over oxygenated but whatever it made the
shift
and in religious cults where they make
you sing or chant a lot
the purpose of that is to hyperventilate
so that you're really susceptible to
passing out that's why you have people
passing out in
in very fundamentalist religious
ceremonies
and so by having people laugh so much
during the first part of the story once
the real
the true nature of the story is revealed
then people are physiologically set up
to faint
and the doctor explains how their head
falls to one side
and then in order to open their airway
their body has to fall to the floor
and so that's what was happening people
were laughing
they were shocked they fell to the floor
what was the motivation or the the itch
that needed to be scratched
in this particular instance it was it
just the challenge of seeing
if you could accomplish
such a feat of sort of uh almost stage
magic
with with a reading uh or was it a
morbid curiosity what was it
it really started with uh i had
two anecdotes and they were so similar
and i knew i couldn't do anything with
two anecdotes
it was like writing a song with two
verses you really need a third verse and
you need a bridge
and so i had an anecdote about a friend
of mine in college
who had been in the marines and
stationed the middle east
and he got very stoned in college and
called me from the hospital and said
that
that he had tried this princess wand
trick
that he had learned in the middle east
or he'd witnessed
these these long brass rods that people
would the men would insert in their
urethra
while they masturbated so he had tried
to do it with
a long drip of wax from a candle and he
ended up in the hospital
and he ended up hugely in debt and
dropping out of college
and then i tied that to an anecdote that
i had heard
about a friend who
wanted to try pegging as an adolescent
and had bought a a carrot but then was
too embarrassed to buy a carrot and
vaseline so he bought all the
ingredients for a carrot cake
and vaseline and i had these two great
anecdotes
that were funny and heartbreaking and
visceral
and it wasn't until i was doing research
for my book choke
that a sexaholic in a sexaholic support
group
was explaining to me that he has always
been 135 pounds
because he had to have a radical bowel
resectioning
and i asked him why and he explained
this
horrible swimming pool story and i
realized i had the third anecdote
that i had the third verse for what
would be kind of a song
that would ultimately make people uh
faint
but that some people have come to me and
and they've told me that it is the
saddest
story they have ever written their lives
and that's always the
the goal is to make people laugh and
then to really break their heart
i've read from you a lesson and this is
a lesson
from consider this uh your book
which i'm gonna read this is something
that was uh in publishers weekly
and you can feel free to of course
correct this but i think it
perhaps connects to to what you're
saying or at least
i'll make that attempt here it is quote
if you're going to work on something as
long as a novel it has to explore some
unresolved
aspect of you so that even if it never
sells never makes any money
never gets any attention you still have
a therapeutic benefit
of fully exploring and exhausting that
unresolved part of you so
you talked about making people laugh and
then breaking their hearts
when you write a shorter piece is there
some
desired impact or process that you want
for yourself in writing that or is it
dissimilar
from novels you know a shorter piece
is about exploring an idea but a shorter
piece is really a fantastic opportunity
to mess with a language to really do an
experiment in restructuring information
and the original short story that became
fight club it became chapter six of
fight club
was was just because i wanted to do a
story in which the transitions were
rules i wanted to use rules as a kind of
chorus a
non-fiction transitional device that
would allow me to
cut together different aspects of the
story like i was cutting film
i could jump around temporally i could
jump around
whether i was in scene or in sort of
observation
as long as i used the came back to the
rules
so a short story is really an experiment
in how to completely reinvent
structuring a story
and what the story is about is always
kind of a secondary thing
so speaking of rules if i'm going to
try to span a bridge to someone i want
to ask you about
could you speak to
how you learn to write and specifically
the name that pops to mind
for me is or maybe it's developed your
styles better
a better way to put it but you could put
it in context tom spanbauer
could you explain to people who tom was
tom was effectively my second writing
teacher
my first writing teacher was a very nice
workshop uh
led by a writer named andrea carlisle
who eventually came to me and said that
that my work was so upsetting to the
other writers who were all
very nice middle-aged people and i was
uh
i was this crazy 25 year old and they
don't
the the other students no longer really
felt safe around me
and so she was asking me to leave the
workshop
but she said a man named tom spanbauer
had just moved to portland from new york
where he had studied at columbia with a
famous editor named
gordon lish and gordon lish
is famous for a lot of things including
being uh
raymond carver's editor being a famous
knife editor
fiction editor at esquire running a
magazine called the quarterly
and really sort of developing a style
called minimalism
and a school of writers who were very
popular at the time
who were known as the minimalists and so
tom had moved to portland
and he was more or less teaching gordon
licious minimalism in a workshop
and that's where i got my my real real
education could you describe that
education
what were some of the the the highlights
or formative inputs
in that education you know there are so
many rules
and as a writer you go into writing
without rules and you tend to just write
in these default ways you've always
thought a story should be
but then tom and and gordon come in and
they say
you may not use thought verbs you have
to
externalize everything the way an actor
would
so that the thought the realization the
the
epiphany occurs within the reader you
can't
dictate emotion like that and by that
you mean
for instance you can't you wouldn't use
verbs like he
wonder or think or realized or believed
or
yeah you can't even use love
yeah it's about staying away from
abstractions
you can't use one inch you can't use it
was a 100 degree day you can't say he
was a six foot tall man
you have to stay away from all
abstractions
because a six foot tall man is somebody
different to
everyone who meets him and so when your
character
says he was six feet tall you're losing
an incredible chance of describing
giving to the reader how the character
perceives
a six fatal man does practicing
that type of writing with that specific
constraint
change your everyday perception of
reality at all in the sense that
having taken a fair number of different
compounds in my life
when you dissociate from labels
or you lose labels perception can
change and i don't want to force this
narrative on you but did that affect
how you walked about in the world
experiencing things when you
disallowed yourself from using those
types of abstractions
it made me really a listening for how
other people describe things
because typically when people are
talking they don't use abstractions
when they're telling a story they are
using a much more intuitive
way of of describing things that is
really linked to their experience
and that's what you're listening for the
way that the people describe
things in what gordon lish would call
burnt tongue this kind of inexact
awkward
um inelegant way of staying saying
something
that says it not in a new fresh way but
also implies the emotion behind the
story
uh a story that's told really
beautifully and smoothly
and elegantly does not carry a lot of
honesty or
or emotion doesn't imply the kind of
stress that's behind the story
so you're looking for ways of kind of
reinventing
storytelling and reinventing reading so
that readers have that fantastic
excitement
that you first had in first or second
grade
once you figured it out and you could
follow these symbols
you want to not just tell a story you
want to completely reinvent the act of
reading
every single time you know i'm looking
at some notes in front of me as i always
do
and there's a term here capital d
capital w dangerous writing
and it's part of part of a line or i
should say a series of lines with
methods for
staying intact could you
speak to first and foremost the
definition of dangerous writing
and go from there well here's an example
you know my parents fought
like animals my parents fought like
crazy and so so much my childhood
and my siblings childhood was about
maintaining peace we would play henry
kissinger
where we would hide in the basement and
once mom and dad once the fighting had
reached this huge crescendo
one of us would be chosen to hurt
themselves
so that a bleeding child or a child with
a broken bone
suddenly had to be dealt with and my
parents couldn't fight anymore
so we played this game of being henry
kissinger
to to calm the waters to kind of
redirect all of their anxiety
and so i really could not be with
conflict
so i wrote the book fight club
which is all about this consensual
structured
controlled way of experiencing
and exploring conflict and violence
uh like you would dance that could
allow everybody who had problems with
conflict
to kind of put their toe in the water
and kind of
experience conflict and develop an
ability to be with it
but be less reactive to it and so
dangerous writing is effectively about
taking an idea something that is
unresolved and threatening to you
and blowing it up and exploring it and
making it
worse than you ever imagined it could be
and in doing so
really exhausting your emotional
reaction to it
and typically that makes the problem
itself go away entirely
are there any other examples of that
that you could give
this seems like an incredibly powerful
therapeutic tool possibly right so you
know speaking
personally as someone who is hyper
reactive to certain things
whether from your own experience or that
of others you've
described this to could you illustrate
any other examples
of how this might apply to exhausting
that that emotional
reactivity well let's talk about
somebody else let's talk about ireland
who is always a hero of mine
uh he wrote rosemary's baby at a time
when
uh women were being given thalidomide
and being told take this it will calm
you down
and women were just controlled and
kind of forced to do whatever the
obstetricians said to do
and regardless of what they were worried
about their concerns were dismissed
nobody could talk about abortion at the
time so
ira levin writes rosemary's baby
which is about a woman who was
manipulated and then completely
controlled
by the medical services around her and
she's coerced into having
this monster of a baby after everyone
has assured her that everything is going
to be just
fine and in doing so ir11
really kind of broke open how women were
able to be
with the whole medical industrial
complex and how they were able to
discuss
abortion it was really one of the first
maybe the first
mainstream movie in which abortion was
openly discussed
and also in an indirect way how
thalidomide was dealt with
culturally all these kind of horrors
that people just could not talk about
openly because they were too
controversial and too frightening
ir11 gave people a metaphor that allowed
them to exhaust
all their feelings around these things
so the things themselves could be dealt
with
directly you mentioned a little bit
earlier
or you described fight club and
the the consensual violence that it
involves and i'd love to
explore a line that i've read of yours
which
abbreviated would be resolution is death
and i'd love to read just a short bit
from an interview
i think it's an interview yes it is in
the guardian
and feel free to fact check of course
but here goes this is a portion of the
quote if i write something that people
can really argue about
that thing is going to be in the culture
forever for example is fight club good
or bad
it's consensual but it's violence i'm
trying to create this dazzling spectacle
that's not meant to perpetuate or
generate anything
but to be a sorbet that allows you to
taste the next thing to be a little more
present in the next thing
and the interviewer asked if you wanted
to see resolution and you said no
especially in creative work
resolution is death and what i would
love to ask is how do you think about
crafting
if you do a satisfying story arc
while maintaining this surface tension
of lack of
resolution if that's a way to put it how
do you think about combining those two
things or either piece
do it the way your dog would do it do
you got a dog i do
all right so when your dog sees a
squirrel
the dog falls into a trance right the
squirrel is a moving thing
and the dog will follow the verb that
motion carries its own authority
and so as long as you keep a character
in action
and the action is always towards a
purpose
and it's not over thought it's not over
analyzed
the story will occur as really good and
engaging
because action is always taking place
and so
as long as you stay in action and you
come back
and you complete an unresolved thing
then there's that sense of satisfaction
you don't have to resolve
the entire world you just have to
resolve one aspect of the world
and that's enough to give people a sense
of
reward you know what i could segue here
to short stories
because i had doors short stories there
just are not enough of them
and i would argue it's because so many
publications pay by the word
so they will pay less for a fantastic
short story than they will for a really
flabby
40 hundred page long long story
do you think there's a way to fix that
is there a simple solution where you
where someone could somehow create
incentives for that to be different
you know what what i'd like to see is uh
i'd like to see more spoken word stories
if you had a program of stories
because what are the stories weren't
always written down stories were
originally somebody that
somebody something that was told by
somebody to an audience
and those are the stories that you
really crave the stories you heard
around the campfire when you were a kid
that really scared the pants off of you
where there were the stories you heard
in the barbershop that made you really
laugh
and so if you adhere to that kind of
oral storytelling model
you could never go long long and so
in a way i would like to see more
stories told out loud
because it automatically limits how long
they can be yeah there's a
inbuilt central governor which is the
vocal cords in memory and so
especially if it's truthful especially
if it's true story although it wouldn't
have to be
can you think of any other parameters if
you were setting up this
experiment any other restrictions or
prerequisites that would go into people
who would be getting up to tell these
stories
the other kind of fail-safe device
that's built in
is it as a teller of stories you know
when when you're dying
you know when that story is just not
landing you can tell from the
what the room is engaged you can tell
from the silence in the room
you can tell from the emotional
reactions from people
right now i'm still trying to conduct my
writer's workshop
and we're doing it on zoom and it is
death
because as you read your work on zoom
you're not getting the ongoing
the laughter the groans the inhales
the fantastic silence of terror you're
not getting any emotional feedback
so it feels like you are failing for 30
or 40 minutes
and if you were in front of an audience
you would know
at what point you had gone way too long
and that you were your story had was
failed
would there be an upper limit would you
say 10 minute max 15
20 30 or would would it be up to each
presenter each storyteller better put
you know andy warhol would say art is
whatever you can get away with
i have heard 40-minute hour-long stories
that felt like 10 minutes same goes for
movies
anything you know the idea is to keep
people engaged on such an intense level
that they lose track of time they are so
completely involved in the story
and so it time doesn't really matter as
long as people's butts don't hurt
and as long as they stay really deeply
immersed in the story
well let's talk about engaging the room
and i do agree the zoom is death right
you can't
hear people shuffling papers out of
boredom or distraction
it's the cues aren't there the feedback
isn't there
what are some of your methods for
engaging the audience and when is it
important to you
to engage the audience you know i would
argue with it right from the get-go from
the first sentence you've got to engage
the audience
and that goes back to a journalism
that your lead has to be really strong
your lead has to raise a question
has to tease something uh
so and if not your lead then at least
your first paragraph
has to really hook the audience it has
to
make them want to read the next sentence
or the next paragraph
and beyond that you know really is about
staying
very visceral or on the body as as tom
would teach it
that you involve a constant sort of
awareness of physicality
so that you're enrolling the reader on a
physical level not just an
emotional or an intellectual level but
you have
the the reader's entire body is in the
story
and that's why so many of my stories
really involve either sex or violence or
illness or or drugs
but something that that heightens the
physical awareness
of the characters what other approaches
whether craft or trickery or perhaps
often the same thing
have you used or seen as being effective
for
engaging the audience there's just so
many little tricks one is
just to constantly be changing the
texture uh to find some way that you can
shift from first person to third person
to second person
the way that people tell a joke
conversationally
and to deliver the story in broken down
articulated bits that will assemble
themselves in the reader's mind
without a lot of connective tissue
without a lot of
transitional phrasing this is why i love
the work of amy hempel so much
is in stories like in the cemetery where
al jolson is buried
she basically presents a list of
fantastic details
without any kind of transitional
narrative linking them together
and the list of details piles up in your
mind
like an attorney presenting bits of
evidence in court
and at the end she doesn't dictate an
emotional state
but she forces the reader to have the
emotional reaction
that her narrator is not having and by
the end of that story you find yourself
weeping so hard and you don't know why
you're weeping so hard
because you haven't been told this is
the sad part
this is where you should cry but she has
so
burdened you with what seemed like
innocuous
moments that you have no other reaction
except for
to uh to have the emotional reaction
that her character's not having i could
go on and on there's so many little
tricks
oh please go on and on that's why this
isn't a five-minute
morning tv show we have the runway
yeah another kind of core thing in
minimalism is that you keep
saying the same thing over and over i
finally got minimalism one day
i left spanbauer's workshop i went home
i turned on television there was a
commercial for skipper's seafood
and the commercial was just a montage of
images
it was the signage it was the the paper
cups it was the napkins
it was people at a table smiling and
happy
uh with with skippers badging all around
them
it was people in uniforms with skippers
badging
and every single one of these images
even though they were all
different images they all basically said
the same thing
and at no point did they insert say a
horse running in the surf
there were no unrelated
aspects it was all saying skipper's
seafood
over and over and so in minimalism
you look for as many different ways as
possible
to say the same thing over and over and
over
so i'm going off notes here but i'm
going to throw out a few prompts
what about making intentional mistakes i
love making
intentional mistakes oh my gosh you know
what is the first thing that scarlett
o'hara says in gone with the wind
i'm gonna fail my my lit class here i
will have to
defer to you she says
war war war all this talk of war
is spoiling all the barbecues there is
not going to be a war
and as soon as she says there is not
going to be a war
we are on board we are thinking
you poor privileged little thing
there is going to be a war and it is
going to completely kick your ass
and it is going to destroy your little
world
but because she said the wrong thing
she makes the audience smarter and she
makes the audience sympathetic with her
and rosemary woodhouse in rosemary's
baby
we know that she's been knocked up by
the devil but she doesn't know
and the fact that she doesn't know makes
us really root for her
so when you have a character who's
making an ongoing
mistake you keep the audience really
engaged because the audience feels
superior
doesn't resent the character and wants
to see the character come to
enlightenment
but there is a kind of condescending
sympathy and nurturing
that the audience feels for a character
who is making a constant mistake
also i love doing this i love
going to a literary party and saying you
know
robert benchley what a fantastic career
that man had
he founded the new yorker and then so
much later in life he wrote the book
jaws
and wow what a fantastic span
of a career and there'll be a long
silence and all these smart people
look at me and then finally someone will
say no
peter benchley wrote jaws and that was
robert benchley's son
and they'll all feel so superior
so smart and they get such a rush
when you allow people to be smart like
that
it's like they've won a game show and
they they might feel a little less
respectful of you
but what's important is that you've made
them feel really good they've got those
chemicals going at that point
and you can really start to jerk them
around
so that i naturally have to ask what
particular flavors of jerking
such people around do you enjoy i really
love
to tell people that sylvia plath was a
racist
she really was she was totally a racist
because she wrote the bell
curve no she wrote the bell jar
and everybody at the party will look at
you puzzled for a moment
and then go no you're such an idiot
she wrote the bell jar and i'm like
what and so it's just terrific to troll
people like that
it validates their education the way
that game shows
when you're sitting and you're yelling
at jeopardy and you get it right
and they get it wrong you feel so
pompous
and it's always about making the
audience
giving the audience a win giving the
audience an ongoing series of wins
and that's a big thing in minimalism is
it you never
want to tell them what is what
until they figure it out first
and going back to the short story guts
but the character is so sure that
this some kind of a snake has come out
of the bottom of their pool
and the snake has a hold of him the
audience
realizes what the snake is before the
narrator does
and that forces the audience to have
this enormous
cognitive reframing and to face the
horror
all alone without being told what the
horror is
in a way we kind of figure out what's in
the box at the end of seven
before brad's hit and that makes us
smarter and more horrified and we're
forced to carry the horror
before brad pitt is allowed the horror
just a quick thanks to one of our
sponsors and we'll be right back to the
show
this episode is brought to you by ship
station the holiday season is fast
approaching and we know that people will
be buying more stuff
online than ever before all of these
trends to e-commerce have been
accelerated due to covid and much more
if you're an e-commerce seller are you
ready to meet the demands of
record-breaking online shopping season
be ready with shipstation
shipstation.com is the fastest
easiest and most affordable way to
manage and ship your orders
in just a few clicks you're managing
orders printing out discounted shipping
labels and getting your products out
fast happier holidays for you and your
customers
shipstation takes the hassle out of
holiday shipping no matter where you're
selling
on amazon etsy your website via shopify
or other platforms
shipstation brings all of your orders
into one simple
interface and shipstation works with all
of the major carriers usps
fedex ups even international you can
compare and choose the best shipping
solution every time
and you can access the same postage
discounts that are usually reserved
for large fortune 500 companies it's no
wonder that shipstation is the number
one choice of online sellers and right
now
my listeners that's you guys can try
shipstation free
for 60 days when you use offer code tim
just go to the homepage shipstation.com
click on the microphone at the top of
the home page and type in
tim tim that's it go to shipstation.com
then enter offer code tim
shipstation.com make ship happen
i'm going to make a hard left turn
since it is my nature to enjoy
non-sequiturs i'd like to discuss lewis
hyde i believe you have
something to say or things to say about
lewis hyde
and i'm also curious to know is this the
same lewis hyde
who has written quite a few books
including one of my favorites which is
trickster makes this world
which is a book really about the
disruptive side of human imagination
as embodied in trickster mythology is
this one in the same lewis hyde
yeah i love that book i think that was
his first book it's
spectacular and it's [ __ ] long just
so people know what they're signing up
for if they get it on kindle or
something
but it's fantastic what would you like
to say
about louis hyde you know there's so
much of luicide that has been so useful
for me because he approaches things from
across culturally
and so you don't just hear about north
american trickster culture with coyote
or raven you hear about loki north
american trickster culture you hear
about mediterranean trickster culture
you hear all these how all these
cultures have this kind of
chaos character which is what i was
writing when i was writing tyler durden
and so seeing how your character falls
into this
ancient tradition of these archetypes
is so important because it allows you to
really
you know write accurately and
effectively
exactly the character that you're
writing and get the effect that you're
going for
you realize you're not kind of inventing
something entirely
new you're reinventing something really
ancient
and there's a wonderful joy in that i
wrote a short story called phoenix which
was about a
a woman on a business trip and she kept
on calling home
and her small daughter would not speak
to her
uh and she kept on trying to get her
husband to coerce her daughter
into saying hi because she had started
to fantasize that perhaps her daughter
might be ill or in the hospital or might
have even been
killed and that the husband the father
does not
want to admit that to her over the phone
so she it all escalates until she tells
her husband
okay you get a pin from my sewing basket
and you stick it in our daughter you
stick it in rachel and you make rachel
scream
if i don't hear rachel scream i'm
calling the police
and they're going to be at the house and
i'm going to tell them that you sexually
abused rachel
and you're going to prison so either you
stick a pin in rachel
or i'll tell people that you stuck
something else in rachel
and the story works so well it escalates
this
this completely horrific no-win
situation
and when i was done with it i realized i
was rewriting
isaac and abraham
it's god saying prove how much you love
me
by stabbing a knife in your kid and
with lewis hyde he helps you identify
the archetype
that you're writing to so that you can
really fulfill that expectation
because if you get that expectation a
tiny bit wrong then on some level the
reader is not going to be really
satisfied with it
stephen king has written about how when
you're writing in a way you're
excavating
some ancient enormous buried thing and
you're trying to excavate it
as intactly as possible without breaking
off any piece of it
and without leaving any of it sort of
obscured with dirt
and the more you understand about
this ancient thing the better you are
reproducing it
in its fullness and so lewis hyde helps
with that
boy the other aspect of lewis hyde that
i'm really fascinated with
is uh is in his book the gift he writes
a great deal about
how according to a greek and roman
tradition
each of us is born with uh effectively a
guardian angel
but it's more along the lines of a guide
that represents our fullest potential
and
this guide wants to see us reach our
fullest potential our greatest form of
power
and the the ancient greeks and the
romans they would make a sacrifice
on their birthday to this whether they
called it their genius
or their daemon or their genie lewis
eye's example is the elves and the
shoemaker
that when the shoemaker is really at a
low ebb the elves
arrive and and begin to make these
fantastic shoes for him
and when the shoemaker finally gives a
gift to them then they're freed from
their bondage
and they leave his life but they leave
his life transformed
and according to this ancient greek and
roman idea
is that if you fulfill your potential if
you sacrifice
and you develop your skills
that are kind of your destiny according
to this
potential you're born with then you free
that guardian spirit
so that that guardian spirit can move on
to another level
in effect you are freeing the genie from
the bottle
and if you do it wrong the genie has to
go back into the bottle
and according to the greeks and the
romans if you did it wrong
then the genie the daemon
the genius becomes a malevolent
household spirit
that will destroy you and destroy your
home uh
and how many of us kind of know a
creative person
who just didn't follow through with it
and ended up drinking
and doing drugs and kind of destroying
their lives
because they didn't have the whatever
to really pursue the passion that should
have been their destiny
but lewis hyde writes about that very
effectively
have you in your own life ever
experienced
the consequences of not
fulfilling your destiny to your
daemon so to speak i mean have you
suffered
the consequences of neglecting that
directional
impulse only every time i'm between a
book
i am emotional and reactionary and
getting drunk
and taking ambien and calling my few
friends in the middle of the night and
saying what do you mean by that
and i'm picking fights and i am just
totally trashing my life
somebody will say you're not writing
right now are you
and that's exactly it because when i'm
writing
all of that negative all that anxiety
goes into the work
and my life is so peaceful and so
productive but when i'm not writing and
also when i'm writing there's this sense
i've talked to other
writers who who write and musicians and
they say that
when you're really deep in a project
there is a sense that you are
so protected and so embraced
by something that nothing bad can happen
to you
you really feel like you're just
completely protected when you're in in
the creative act
and when you're not you're just
completely anxious
you seem to be a real student of
mythology
and i'd like to ask you two at least two
things about that the first is
do you find some solace in
mythology is it reassuring in some way
and second
could you speak to joseph campbell's
theory
of the second father boy the uh
a million years ago i did not have
television all through college
and then all through the 90s and uh
someone
taped the the joseph campbell pbs
uh lecture series uh um bill
the power of myth with bill moyers yes
exactly
spectacular yeah and up to that point
i had looked at black street gangs
and thought these guys are idiots you
know
they're so destructive so negative and
so
you know without purpose and then joseph
campbell mentioned the secondary father
and he said what's going on in black
street gangs
is that they're getting the secondary
father
in terms of being given tasks being
given challenges being given roles
and being given this opportunity to kind
of distinguish themselves
and to grow their skills in what are
you know more or less illegal ways but
there's still ways of developing the
individual
so that the individual will eventually
rise out of that gang
and live a productive life in some other
way but the problem is that
more and more people who used to be the
secondary fathers in our culture
and these are say military drill
sergeants
or religious leaders or teachers or
coaches are becoming stigmatized
and they're no longer kind of revered
figures in the culture
you know blame it on a lot of things on
sexual abuse
on whatever but all these secondary
fathers
are disappearing and they're important
for both men and women
so without them what happens
street gangs happen and so i i don't
think we can complain about
street gangs unless the secondary father
is available in some other form
does anything outside of being immersed
in a writing project make you feel
protected or at ease if you share the
same sentiment as
your other writing friends that brought
this to the surface in conversation
no you know i could lie i would lie i
would lie and i would say vicodin
yeah you know find me some vicodin
and all and i'll be a happy camper but
no that's that's
an artificial sense of safety and
insecurity no the only time is when i
feel like i'm fulfilling some kind of
destiny
and i feel like i've kind of lost myself
and i've become a conduit
for something deeper and more important
to myself
and so often it puts me into
conversation with other people
because i tell them what i'm working on
and i'm so constantly looking for
different
ways of reinventing skipper's seafood
over and over
in a book and so i need to take the
topic
to every single person and i need to see
if it resonates with them
that's what we do at parties is that you
go to a party
and the story you tell if it shuts the
room down and everyone's
quiet that's not necessarily a great
story
but if the room erupts with everyone
having
a different version of that same story
that all starts with oh my gosh the same
thing happened to me
only bigger then that's a good story
and so if you take your topic to other
people and it resonates with each of
them enough
that they can sort of tell their
experience of it
and they can also tell you whether or
not it's already been
exploited in commercial culture they can
say oh i saw that in a movie
so you're testing whether people engage
with it you are
expanding it using other people's
experience
and you're also making sure that it
wasn't already explored to
some other sort of commercial narrative
how old
were you if you recall when you
began writing and finished fight club
just a little aside uh doug copeland
the guy who wrote generation x is a
friend of mine
and reading generation x was kind of a
an epiphany for me
it was such a unique fantastic book
and it was a book i read before i really
started to write
but doug copeland had told me that he
had just read
a bunch of brain studies that showed
that the last
sort of physiological physical changes
in the human brain occur
around the age of 31 so that it's at the
age of 31
the people for the very first time can
combine their experience with their
education
and create something that is greater
than just the sum of the two
so it tends to be between the age of 31
and typically 33 that people who have
studied in a field
create their breakthrough or create
their masterpiece
the the proof of their of their their
competence
and so it really was at the age of 33
that i wrote fight club
but i very much i started writing it
more or less
when i was 31 and finished it at 33.
another interesting aspect to that brain
study
is that this studies show that for the
rest of people's lives
no matter how old they get if you ask
them
how old do you feel
almost everyone will say you know i feel
like i'm
i always feel like i'm 31.
that really is a formative uh
period between 31 and 33. when they were
reborn in their full feature set at 31
that's wild how can or how does
narrative generate social change you
know
i've always hated narrative that tries
to dictate
social change and i've always felt that
the most effective way that it could
generate
social change is
creating and presenting an alternative
that is so attractive that it makes
people just readily abandon what they
were doing before
and my favorite examples are here in the
pacific northwest
we had this huge problem with beavers
beavers
are choking all the waterways with
chewed down trees
the beavers have become a fantastically
dense pest but
a hundred years ago beavers were almost
extinct because the hudson bay company
had come in and set up all these
trapping forts and these uh ways of
buying beaver pelts
because beaver was the fur for hats
everyone wanted a beaver hat and so
beaver was being driven to extinction
for beaver skin hats and it wasn't
people
protesting it wasn't people you know
chaining themselves to trees
it wasn't anything like that that saved
the beavers
it was the british creating the silk top
hat
and silk hats suddenly became the
fashion
and something is that seems as silly as
fashion
saved beavers because suddenly nobody
wanted old-fashioned beaver hats
they wanted silk top hats and suddenly
beaver had no value whatsoever as a
commodity
and so suddenly beavers were left
unmolested for 100 years
and now beavers are everywhere i love
that story because people think that
the arts don't really create social
change
but when they change the narrative when
they just change what people perceive as
valuable or high status
then they naturally get
people to change without having to
browbeat people
or legislate change another sort of
odd example my italian editor eduardo
told me years ago how the italian fur
industry back in the 90s
it was doing really well fur was very
popular with
wealthy and celebrity italians
but they decided they really wanted to
grow the fur market
so the fur industry decided that they
would finance furs
so that middle class and even lower
class people
could buy fur minks
chinchillas coats whatever they could
buy them on installments like you would
buy a house or a car
and tons of lower class people
bought tons of fur and for a brief
moment the firm market exploded
in italy but then the rich people saw
all the poor people wearing fur
and the rich people thought no for his
uh
there's no longer a status indicator so
they dropped fur
and the celebrities dropped fur and
suddenly the poor people saw that the
rich
people didn't wear fur anymore and the
poor people dropped fur
and the italian fur industry has never
really recovered from that
and it's not because somebody said fur
is evil and threw a bloody raccoon
at the devil wears prada at anna wintour
it wasn't because of any kind of
political thing
it was because the narrative changed
and it changed in that kind of
inadvertent accidental way
and i think that's what really good
writing or really good
any storytelling does it makes me think
i've never heard that example before
that story it makes me think
about what some people maybe in new york
would describe as
flying rats pigeons pigeons
started off in a sense and as display
birds of the aristocracy
and they got out turns out they multiply
very well
and now they're thought of as trash
birds they're actually very beautiful
beautiful beautiful birds but all it
takes is releasing
whether it's birds or ideas sometimes
into the wild to change the narrative
are there any other examples that come
to mind you know there's some
speculative examples
uh they're not actual examples but uh
when you change the listening how
it really kind of skews how people
perceive things
nowadays whenever i see uh like a
middle-aged guy walking down the street
with a
really pretty little girl i think i
wonder how they met
i go to that jeffrey epstein place
instead of seeing a father and a
daughter
and the jeffrey epstein thing has just
totally tainted
how i see an older man
and a younger woman together and so
that's one example
of uh of how when the listening changes
uh it sort of taints everything like
pigeons
another example is uh the wizard of oz
somebody pointed out that dorothy gets
back home by clicking our heels together
and that's a movie that was released in
1939 when
flicking your heels together was a
really nazi thing
so is it wizard of oz actually kind of a
white supremacist movie
this all this heel clicking all this i
don't know
suddenly the optics are really bad on
the wizard of oz
so it just takes these really small
things to to shift the perspective
have you ever thought now i don't mean
to imply doing it very on the nose in a
direct
way if i'm remembering correctly you
said you dislike
when art or narrative in the form of art
tries to directly catalyze social change
feel free to correct me but
have you ever used narrative to
obliquely
indirectly surreptitiously generate
social change or in hopes of doing so
you know
if i've done it it was just to kind of
raise an awareness
you know in my book beautiful you which
is uh
is about uh sex toys that are so
effective that they basically take over
the world
the book was started because i was a
little appalled
seeing the trojan twister advertised so
openly
during prime time television and
i thought it was just fascinating that
what used to be very personal
interpersonal interactions were being so
commodified
we don't know how to say we love each
other so there's
aisles and aisles of cards that will say
it for us
and there's all these recording artists
that will express our love for us
and you know people are kind of losing
all of these really
intimate ways of connecting expressing
because they can buy
something that they feel is better than
they could do themselves
and beautifully you was very much about
talking about this uh commodification of
of the personal and how ultimately that
takes away
our ability to express anything
and we lose all control so sometimes i
am a little
dogmatic this is going to be an
ill-formed
question but i'll make an attempt anyway
and this this is of course
a leading question that is full of
assumptions but what what is it that
draws you to cults
and are we in the moment of cults i
wouldn't even say cults as much as i
would say social models
i'm always fascinated by different
social models the kind of
games that people invent for you know
how to conduct their lives
that somebody has created all these
rules and
everyone has agreed to it to play by
these rules i find that fascinating
because it is an acceptance that that is
a consensual
sort of behavior mutually agreed upon
set of behaviors that are going to
define our culture and make it work
one aspect is i love the work of victor
turner
who is a british sort of cultural
anthropologist
because he identified like lewis hyde
all these liminal and lymnoid rituals
that people do and one
lymnoid rituals are when people get
together
in a mutually sort of agreed-upon
situation like whether it's burning man
in the desert
or it's occupy wall street but they get
together
with a sense of communitas where the
social hierarchy is flattened
everyone is equal and they kind of
experiment to see
if they can come up with a different way
of being together they experiment with
fashion they experiment with food
with just how to conduct themselves with
each other and how to
manage themselves and they also
experiment with their identities
and so people go to burning man and
they're not who they are
in the rest of the world they're a
unique burning man
person for that one week and so
ideally if those experiments are
successful
they get adopted into the culture and
they become
the new institutions and years ago
before i started writing
i got wrapped up in the cacophony
society which was
about nothing but creating these kind of
experiential
social experiments like burning man like
santa rampage
and most of which did not work
they just fell down they were horrible
failures but some of which
have become huge celebrated things like
the naked bike ride
and santa rampage and burning man
you used a word just a moment ago that i
did not recognize which is
liminoid could you define that please
now let's start with the word liminal
which sort of comes from
threshold or lentil it's a line that you
pass over
from one state of being to the next as
in subliminal
uh just etymologically right i mean it
would be
local awareness yeah below awareness or
the threshold of awareness
and liminal events happen
throughout our lives the honeymoon is
held up as an
archetypal liminal event that it is what
divides you from being a single person
to being a married person
so you are wedded in front of your
community
so your whole community is seeing you
wetted but then you have to leave the
community for typically three days
that the the classic honeymoon is a
liminal
event where you leave the culture for
three days
and when you come back you are fully
recognized as being
husband and wife and you go to some
place that is outside of the culture
you know a resort someplace that is
not part of your everyday life there are
liminoid events
funerals or limonoid events weddings
halloween is a great linoid event
another distinction of limnoid events is
that they tend to have a
power hierarchy reversal in them that at
halloween
all the people who have no power dress
up as
outlaws they dress up as cowboys or they
dress up as the dead
or they cross dress or they dress as
animals
they dress as something outside of the
normal
and then they go to people who do have
power and property
and they demand tribute from them so
the hierarchy is reversed for one night
uh
halloween used to be just a major [ __ ]
show
people used to tear down fences they
used to
slash tires they used to really destroy
a lot of property
until the 1920s when
the newspapers got together with the
insurance companies
and the candy companies and decided to
promote halloween
to change the listening like pigeons to
change it so that
if you went door to door and asked for
candy people would give you candy
and that was basically just a way of
saving a huge amount of insurance
claims i started in canada in toronto
but it really you know that's what we
see as halloween now
christmas was kind of the same way that
christmas carolers would go around
and caroling was a really menacing thing
caroling meant either you come out and
you give us
booze or food or gold or we will break
your windows
they're paid to go away and so was uh
fashion
or mardi gras that it was traditionally
the one time
when poor people could go into the
church and eat their greasy food
and do all these kind of outrageous
things and the clergy
did kind of profane things and it was
during fashion it was during
the period before lent that martin
luther
nailed up his uh his protests so that's
why
protestant religions have never had
power hierarchy reversal
rituals because that's how they kind of
came into power
and they don't want to provide that
opportunity for something to go wrong
again
and and extending that to limnoid
liminal events are things that happen at
regular junctures in the culture
christmas funerals weddings halloween
before lent easter but
limnoid events are events that have the
characteristics
of liminal events they tend to have
communitas
they're outside of the regular world
they have
social leveling of the of the power
hierarchy
but they can occur at any time they tend
to be things that you
you purchase your way into like a
concert like burning man
i'd love to do a flash back and a flash
forward
or flashed present perhaps in
the process of doing homework for this
conversation i came across a phrase
i had never come across before and that
is
kiss off money
as it relates to fight club could you
please explain
what this means and uh how it relates
to fight club oh you know i uh
i have such misgivings about ever having
mentioned this
because it really hurt my editor's
feelings
years ago when fight club was being shot
around as a manuscript
there was this really brave guy jerry
howard
at wwe norton and jerry wanted to
acquire the book for norton so bad
and finally he got norton to offer six
thousand dollars on it
which he brought to me and i was
thrilled
i had no idea that six thousand dollars
was uh a really small advance
and then years later i mentioned it to
another norton author
and she said oh
you accepted the [ __ ] you money
and i said you know what's that and she
said if the house
does not want to acquire a book but they
don't want to alienate the editor
who wants to acquire the book they offer
in advance
so low that the author is supposed to
say [ __ ] you
and walk away and i had no idea i was
young i'd never done this before i was
working at freightliner
so i just took the money but then i made
the mistake of repeating
what this other author had told me and
uh became part of the public record and
you know ultimately hurt the feelings of
the editor who had acquired
you know the money for me but uh you
know that's
kind of what it's known is is politely
it's known as kiss off money
i got the disney version now people at
least people of my generation
certainly think of fight club as this
cultural mainstay i mean this real
landmark uh piece of narrative
in marquee lights how many copies
did it sell in the first year in
hardcover would you estimate
boy it was dismal they sent me on a four
city tour
and i never had more than one or two
people at any cities
i ended up in livermore livermore
california
with no one and uh i doubt
if it sold 2000 copies in its first year
hardcover
and even in 1999 when the movie was
coming out
most of the hardcovers were still in the
warehouse and they were about to be
pulped
turned back into recycled paper
when someone mentioned that a movie was
coming out so they they kept the
hardcovers
and subsequently sold them all but uh it
sold
tiny numbers just in really nothing
numbers
it sold a little better as a paperback
but no it was a
big bomb at the beginning this is going
to be a lazy question but i'll ask it
anyway because i'm so curious
having never had anything made into a
movie
how would you summarize what your
experience was like
going from pre-movie to say
a few years after the movie came out how
do you
summarize or describe that experience i
really can't even imagine
emotionally what it looked like or felt
like i could only talk about it
i always try to be as specific as
possible and address maybe just one
aspect of something
rather than try to sort of generalize
about the entire thing
and one interesting aspect that i've
grown to appreciate
is that when you do a thousand pressed
junkets
for a movie and you're asked the same
questions
over and over it's kind of like the
whole buddhist concept of look again
look again look again and it's as if
you're being
psychoanalyzed by a million strangers
who have no emotional attachment to your
action to your answer
so but you are still looking a little
deeper and trying to reinvent the thing
every time
you look at it and so often it takes
that kind of
really thorough coaching before you
realize what you actually wrote about
and suddenly you can realize in the
middle of a
some room full of reporters the thing
the dark
secret horrible thing that you were
actually writing about
and you can be mortified you put this
thing on the page
and then you spend the whole rest of
that meeting with a smile just pinned on
your face
praying that no one will ever realize
what you were actually writing about
and uh it's painful but i would rather
it happens eventually
then never happen it because it's it's
extraordinary
to see how your subconscious was working
that whole time
and in a way as you're writing you were
trying to trick yourself
to go to a place you would never
consciously go to
and at the same time you're trying to
trick the reader
to go to a place that they would never
consciously go to
and to have a reaction to something that
they do not want to fully recognize
and that's kind of the glory of
minimalism i don't expect an answer here
so feel free not to answer if you prefer
but
what did you discover what were you
actually writing about
oh hell no i'm not going to go there now
you know number one because it's always
so fantastically dark
and personal and suppressed
and number two i'm afraid if i ever get
that specific
with my intention it will preclude the
reader's
sort of interpretation and it won't have
any power for the reader because
suddenly there'll be this correct
interpretation
and if it's the reader doesn't conform
to that then the reader is wrong
and again it's never about making the
reader wrong it's about making the
reader
right and giving them a rush of being
right over and over
couldn't have asked for a better answer
thank you for that do you ever worry
after writing something or at any point
that you will write something and at
some point be sitting in a meeting
and you have this flash of insight about
what you were actually writing about
that is so dark that it plunges you
headlong into some type of abyss that is
difficult to
climb out of no it's never really
as if it's plunged into an abyss because
any kind of revelation like that
is such a relief it's gaining access
being able to
retrieve something that had been so
completely lost
to me that i feel a fantastic joy when
even those darkest things come to the
surface
yeah because at least i know what i'm
dealing with and i'm no longer used by
it i'm using
it and this my advice to writers
dangerous writing is that
so many of us are used by aspects of our
history our past our experience
without fully understanding them and
once we can
unpack them in the seemingly innocuous
world of fiction
then we can more fully look at them and
be aware of them
and not be used by them yeah you have no
idea how
helpful that is to where i am right now
but this conversation isn't about me
so i'll put a pin in that i would love
to ask you about the selection
of subjects how you decide
for instance in the case of your new
book the invention of sound
you could write about anything and
everything to the extent that you're
comfortable describing it what is this
new book about and how did you choose
to write this book i am always
fascinated by the commodification
of human things we are so constantly
finding ways of buying and selling
things
that have never been a commodity before
and i had started with the idea of
someone who collected human screams
and in doing so basically killed people
in order to record their
ultimate scream and when i was doing a
rough draft of the story
i mentioned it to a friend and he said
have you heard of the wilhelm scream
and the wilhelm scream uh is a famous
scream from the 1940s it's been used in
dozens of movies hundreds of video games
cartoons television everything the
wilhelm scream is everywhere
and at the same time i was writing it
a cover artist for fight club 3 drew a
tattoo artist
who was wearing a concert t-shirt
for a band called the wilhelm scream
and suddenly all these strange
coincidences the wilhelm scream
was coming to me from so many different
directions
unrelated directions that i thought ah
this is this is all confirmation
this is what i should be working on and
so i would mention to other people and
they told me about the goofy hauler
they told me about the howie scream they
told me about
tape bleed you know i meet with so many
recording engineers
doing radio shows or doing podcasts or
doing audio books and they all have some
fantastic
story and so you know it gave me a way
to kind of
fish for the information from people who
really know it and then it gave me a
structure for assembling it all together
and on an emotional level it's it's
about a guy who
is searching for his daughter who might
have been killed for one of these
screams
and this is the character i kind of go
back to
the father who has killed or lost his
child
i i find that people engage with it
really intensely
and i think i engage with it i just
realized this is a fairly safe
revelation
but i don't have kids and i won't have
kids
and i think i've reached a point in my
life where i'm beginning to really panic
and mourn
the loss of not having kids and i can
express that through writing a character
whose big purpose is to find
what became of his dead child or if his
child was
killed so without realizing
i was ex you know expressing that aspect
of myself
but i find that that character resonates
with a lot of my peers
who have chosen not to have kids
that that character is really you know
hits home for them
well chuck i gotta say man you are
incredibly
fun to interview i'm sorry
it sounds kind of downer-ish doesn't it
it's uh not said
i'm not saying that as a tale on what
you just said
i legitimately mean that this has been a
lot of fun for me
and i don't always say that for what
it's worth and
i've taken copious notes as we've been
talking for myself
and i hope this is not our last
conversation although i have no
expectations of future conversations
is there anything else that you would
like to
share or discuss i feel like this has
been such
a densely packed rich
master class from you on a multiple
number of levels that i'm feeling very
complete
and hopefully it'll be time for a second
conversation sometime but is there
anything else that you would like to say
or add
comment upon complain about
it's funny because the more you have
access to
the entire sweep of your life and in a
way every one of my books is a diary
of what i was going through at that
point in my life and also kind of a
diary
of things that my friends were going
through
so it's almost like a cross peer group
diary of a group of people during that
time
each book is sourced from so many
different people and recently i
i was watching the news like everybody
else and i was watching the looting
and just kind of appalled you know
people stealing stuff you know from saks
fifth avenue people stealing stuff from
downtown portland
i mean downtown portland is just a giant
looting festival
and i remarked the same to some friends
and one of my friends who had read my
book invisible monsters
said you're one to talk you grew up
looting things
and i realized i did my dad worked for
the railroad
and in the middle of the night when he
would get word that a train had derailed
anywhere in the west he would come home
you know one two three o'clock in the
morning and he would have us
kids all get in the pickup and we would
drive for hours
across deserts and mountains to wherever
this train was smashed up
and our job was to steal as much as we
could from the train as possible
and so we would steal typing paper by
the reams or we would steal
cases and cases of butterscotch pudding
and my mother
did not approve of this but she had read
daphne de marie's book
jamaica inn which was a huge book in the
mid-century
and it depicted the what we call the
wreckers on the west coast of ireland
people who would walk up and down
beaches with
lanterns and give ships the impression
that there was a harbor there
so that ships would crash on the rocks
and then the wreckers would loot the
ships and kill any survivors
and so daphne de mourier very
romanticized
looting okay white people do it too
looting
and so it was delightful
that my friends who had read invisible
monsters
remembered that i had looted trains as a
small child
and really my whole peer group my whole
small town would be there
everyone would be looting that train
before you know somebody would show up
to stop us
and so by writing the books you're able
to kind of
make your deepest darkest history
into part of public record so that when
you do
say something stupid the whole world can
call you on it
and that's that's a nice kind of
coaching
[Laughter]
i love it fantastic chuck chuck palanik
you can find chuckpalinic.net at chuck
palahniuk on twitter facebook instagram
i will put all of this as well as
notes and links to everything that we
discussed in the show notes at tim dot
blog forward slash podcast
chuck what a pleasure hey tim thank you
very much
i really really appreciate the time and
to
everybody listening until next time
thanks for tuning in
and don't forget sylvia plath author of
the bell curve bell jar
i know
hey guys this is tim again just a few
more things before you take off
number one this is five bullet friday
do you want to get a short email from me
would you enjoy getting a short email
from me every friday
that provides a little morsel of fun
before the weekend
and five bullet friday is a very short
email where i share
the coolest things i've found or that
i've been pondering over the week
that could include favorite new albums
that i've discovered it could include
gizmos and gadgets and all sorts of
weird [ __ ] that i've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as i do
it could include
favorite articles that i've read and
that i've shared with
my close friends for instance and it's
very short
it's just a little tiny bite of goodness
before you head off for the weekend so
if you want to receive that
check it out just go to four
hourworkweek.com that's
4hourworkweek.com all spelled out and
just drop in
your email and you will get the very
next one and if you sign up
i hope you enjoy it this episode is
brought to you by thrive
market thrive market saves me a ton of
money and it's perfect for these crazy
times
thrive market is a membership-based site
on a mission to make healthy living
easy and affordable for everyone you can
regularly save 25 to 50
off of normal retail prices with
member-only prices for
anything you can imagine really whether
it's keto paleo gluten-free vegan
whatever you can sort by that
you can find all types of food you can
find supplements you can find non-toxic
home products
clean wine dog food just about anything
and let me give you a personal example
of just how much you can save
so my last order i ordered primal
kitchen
mayonnaise which is made with avocado
oil it's delicious justin's almond
butter
and the first was 25 off the
justin's almond butter was 30 off rau's
homemade
marinara sauce which is awesome 26 off
all said and done at the end of my
shopping i saved
on my order so members and i'm a member
can earn wholesale prices every day and
save an average of 30
on each order i'll come back to that and
through thrive
gives their one-on-one membership
matching program every paid
thrive market membership is matched with
a free one for a low income family in
need so go to thrivemarket.com
tim today to give thrive market a try
you can select the membership model that
best fits your lifestyle they have one
month
and 12 month membership options choose a
free gift up to 22
in value when you join today and
purchase the one year membership and
just remember
thrive market membership is risk free
you can take the first 30 days to decide
if thrive market is right for you
if it's not just cancel within those 30
days and get a full refund
this is what i offered my mom so again
that's thrivemarket.com
tim by the way my mom kept using it
thrivemarket.com
tim check it out this episode is brought
to you by
butcherbox butcherbox makes it easy for
you to get high quality humanely raised
meat
you can trust they deliver delicious 100
grass-fed crafts finished beef
free-range organic chicken
heritage breed pork and wild caught
seafood directly to your door
for me in the past few weeks i've cooked
a ton of other salmon as well as two
delicious barbecue rib racks in the oven
super simple they were the most
delicious pork ribs i've ever prepared
my freezer is full of butcher box when
you become a member
you're joining a community focused on
doing what's better for all that means
caring about the lives of animals
the livelihoods of farmers treating our
planet with respect and enjoying
better meals together butcherbox
partners with folks small farmers
included who believe in going above and
beyond
when it comes to caring for animals the
environment and sustainability
and none of their meat is ever given
antibiotics or added hormones
so how does it work it's pretty simple
you choose your box and
your delivery frequency they offer five
boxes
four curated box options as well as the
popular custom box so you get exactly
what you
and or your family love box options and
delivery frequencies can be customized
to fit your needs you can cancel
at any time with no penalty butcherbox
ships your order frozen for freshness
and packed in an eco-friendly 100
recyclable box
it's easy it's fast it's convenient
i really really enjoy it and best of all
looking at the average cost it works out
to be less than
six dollars per meal for a limited time
new members can get two pounds of free
ground beef in every butcher box order
by signing up today at butcherbox.com
tim that's up to 180 in savings per year
check it out all the details and goodies
can be found at butcherbox.com
tim again that's butcherbox.com
[Applause]
tim
you